yo what's up everybody my other with you
here with another Dark Souls 3 tutorial
now in this video I'm gonna be showing
you guys how to respect your character
you can only do this 5 times per
character so be careful with your usage
of this so you're gonna want to start
from the cleansing chap like a fill of
the deep and go through the second
shortcut if you don't have the second
shortcut open you're gonna need to
progress through the cathedral the deep
until you get it go up the elevator and
you're gonna keep progressing as you see
me do we're gonna go up the ladder we're
gonna be heading towards Rosario who at
is a covenant holder and is the person
who respects your skill points for you
so again follow my path Dean it's not
too difficult of a route if you just
stay on towards there will be a okay
amount of enemies but you don't have to
worry too much about him you can run
past most of them once you get to the
other side of the ceiling drop down and
once you get into this room you don't
want to pop the lever so the third wall
goes up so you have ease of access to
this area from the other side this is
the only way to open the third wall you
can kill these enemies you can run past
them I kill these ones I run past the
next ones see if their wall is up and
once you get to this next area you there
are a good amount of enemies but you can
just run past them open up the doors and
where that is going to be basically it
we're gonna be at Rosario there's give
me a bonfire and then there's gonna be
Rosario who we can talk to and she if
you talk to her say yes to her covenant
pledged her she'll give you her little
medallion and then for a I think at the
cost of a pale tongue which you can get
by doing stuff for [ __ ] covenant anger
covenant is invading Rosario fingers for
a pale tongue you can reset your
character however it costs you can only
do it five times per character so be
very prudent I don't do it in this video
because I'm just showing you guys where
it is but I don't want to respect my
character and I'm not gonna use the one
out of five times because that's a kind
of a big deal to use and I'm pretty good
with my build at the moment so guys hope
you enjoyed this video if you have make
sure you check out my channel for more
Dark Souls 3 content since I have a good
amount of stuff up there I'm gonna be
continuing to post stuff and yeah thank
you for watching and peace out